un exercice exigeant de la france et de
l'onu elle a crû de passe temps à danser
tout une affaire d'hommes dénudés
qu'elle dit
tout le monde
pour que seraient alors les balais du
roi tout comme molière c th
passionné de musique black gerra prévu
devolo 6,52 qu'hollywood 14 celle d'un
bois qui doit vous c'est tout le jeu
comment 20 ans de sauveur que savez-vous
de l'état je veux gouverner seule ma
mère c'est que je crois pouvoir le faire
bien quant à mon goût pour les ballets
sachez ceci mon père a fondé l'académie
de la langue française
je ferai celle de la danse ce sera mon
premier acte de gouvernement
il aura fallu quatre mois de répétitions
et benoît magimel
il faut de la poigne il s'accroche il
faut que ça
chaque planche au moins était comment
comme un boxeur 48 heures
c'est véritablement une danse de pouvoir
et c'est vrai quand on quand on pense à
dance marrant qu'on voit une danse
maniéré une danse très très sophistiquée
et un peu voulu changer tout ça comme la
passion que veut-il et lully pourront
voir julie personnage kobe vi père de
six enfants
le condamné par les dévoués au
libertinage
lee qui se blesse a mortellement à ce
sombre anne venue l'écouter
moi d'amour ou aménagement du toit rien
ne nous dit qu'il ya eu un véritable
amour en tout cas de la part de lully
pour lui 14 c'est quelque chose qui nous
semblait intéressant toute façon rien ne
dit non plus que cette histoire telle
que nous la concevons d'une telle que
nous la recomptant dans le film d'après
existait du droit comme rri
vous y serez des dents
issoire toujours des souvenirs
oh